cette commémoration donc résonne encore
aujourd'hui très fortes dissensions luc
ferrandez bonsoir partout qu'il ya eu je
le rappelle il ya eu un instant sur je
commence avec vous 18 féminicide cette
année uniquement au québec donc la
violence faite aux femmes
il ya eu des progrès depuis je vous
entends de là dessus sur les armes à feu
sur d'autres mesures mais il ya encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire et encore
beaucoup de progrès à 32 ans 14 femmes
se sont fait tuer parce que parce qu'ils
étaient femme parce qu'ils étaient
femmes et qui voulaient travailler et
qu'il y avait quand même un bon futur
deux amis à moi que j'ai perdu dans
cette tuerie j'étudiais à l'université
juste à côté le pavillon ça nous a
touchés profondément mois depuis 32 ans
le 6 décembre n'a jamais été pareil et
on sera vraiment tout ça mais
aujourd'hui je faisais le constat on est
trente deux ans plus tard qu'est ce
qu'on a appris de cet événement le à
l'époque on se dit ça pas de bon sens
quatorze jeunes filles les armes à feu
il ya eu une loi sur les armes à feu le
contrôle des armes à feu on dirait quand
on tourne en rond toujours encore le
jour de la marmotte parce que parce qu'à
32 ans plus tard on est là après onze
mois encore une fois avec 18 de
féminicide encore des femmes avec les
armes à feu qui sont présents sur le
terrain de plus en plus on parle on
parle puisqu'on parle de contrat où on
n'est pas capable contrôler et encore
beaucoup de choses on dirait qu'on est
pas on n'a pas encore appliqué
correctement dit des choses qu'on devait
faire ma job je reviens ni juste une
seconde avant de passer la parole à luc
budget ti est ce que cette journée là
vous étiez l'université pas la police
bien sûr n'est pas loin vous étiez lâché
et je t ai juste dans le pavillon à côté
mon frère était chargé de cours dans la
classe où il ya eu le plus de décès ça
nous a touchés profondément parce que
bon c'est solide on pense pas que c'est
pour arriver à des gens qu'on connaît
c'est arrivé là avec des gens qu'on
connaissait et pour moi ça moche ça m'a
vraiment touché le marquer beaucoup je
compte wood frère était excusé moi ça
m'a échappé des chargés de cours cette
journée l'oeil était absent il est à vos
côtés à la maison mais c'étaient ses
étudiantes qui est hélas le cas ni dit
est ce qu'on a appris quelque chose mais
quand même bon il ya eu une annonce pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière sur
les bracelets électroniques le
rapprochement il ya eu
bannissement d'un certain nombre d'arh
dation quand même il ya eu du chemin un
peu non le passé oui puis on a plus que
jamais du moins pour la violence faite
aux femmes mais le problème c'est que
c'est un mélange de santé mentale de
sentiments d'exclusion de paranoïa qui
ne touche pas les tenues des tueries ça
ne touche pas que les femmes il ya eu
des tissus genre de vue à la grande
mosquée québec il ya eu six grandes
tueries depuis 40 ans plus de quatre
personnes au québec
donc à la mosquée à l'assemblée
nationale à la polytechnique à concordia
etc dont ils se sont toujours des
personnes qui sont difficiles à capter
de capter leur folie meurtrière est
extrêmement difficile alors oui il faut
contrôler les armes et oui faut envoyer
un message de refus de la violence
contre les femmes mais même en faisant
ça il va rester des personnes qui sont
qui sont désaxé et qui commettent des
crimes y en a eu 12 majeurs au canada et
c'est difficile de trouver un fil
conducteur il ya même peut-être y en a
une récemment en nouvelle écosse vous
rappeler yann et au nouveau brunswick il
ya eu une grille une via ton proto bien
nicolas bon c'est souvent des personnes
qui ressentent de l'exclusion
souvent face aux femmes est souvent face
au lieu d'études donc soit dans les
universités déjà que j'ai exclu des
universités eua l'or extrait une
relation amoureuse
est-ce que face à face avec divorce
c'est les deux grands thèmes mais ça
c'est que vous avez raison le soyez luxe
et des cd geste exceptionnel puis
heureusement puis c'est dur à mettre le
grappin sur ces gens là à va céder mais
la violence quotidienne ordinaire
qui tue des femmes ça c'est beaucoup
plus répandu ces hommes qui violentent
des femmes hanine oui puis on a vu
beaucoup pendant la plaque au vide où
les gens étaient à la maison c'est là on
a vu les corps ressortir davantage même
chose avec la dpj avec les enfants on se
rend compte que il n'ya pas de limite à
ça et effectivement comme le diapo d'un
modèle c'est pas tout le monde et fait
pareil qui vont réagir de la même façon
chaque cas est différent chaque raison
de faire cette violence le est
différente c'est difficile de pouvoir
cibler ces gens là ça serait trop facile
de dire écoute et un comportement comme
ça on le voit aussi on va le suivre
c'est saviez de partout bon c'est le jeu
souligne quand même
bracelet annonce groupes communautaires
qui seront mieux subventionné à ton
première donc il ya quand même des
choses qui se font oui non et il reste
un gros morceau c'est le chemin à partir
du moment où les gens sentent qu'elles
ne peuvent pas quitter les femmes ne
peuvent pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres
destinations et elle accepte de vivre
avec un homme qui est profondément
malade c'est une grosse grosse massue
quand même très bien on change
totalement de sujets je vous présente un
reportage mathieu prost qui est allé
dans le magasin et dans outremont sur la
question des synagogues doit-on donner
l'autorisation de la communauté juive
hassidique de construire ou en fait
d'aménager plus de synagogues on écoute
le reportage vous restez
l'arrondissement d'outremont et le mile
end voisins sont des quartiers auquel
les juifs hassidiques sont très attachés
et ils savent que la cohabitation
demande des efforts
abraham eckstein fréquente la synagogue
au point de saint viateur et hodgson
il ya toujours de travail à faire pour
améliorer notre meilleur ensemble nous
sommes ici pour rester donc il faut
trouver des façons de murs ensemble en
paix des façons que nous sommes tous
leur bonheur dans l'immédiat passerait
par un accès facilité à de nouveaux
lieux de culte pour avoir un portrait
précis des besoins l'arrondissement
outremont a demandé à ce professeur en
sciences des religions de dresser un
état des lieux ce qu'il explique d'abord
c'est l'importance de la synagogue dans
plusieurs aspects de la ville à la
différence d'une église par exemple
c'est comme un café en europe on va
partager un café où on va discuter donc
l'exiguïté des lieux le manque de
confort la vétusté également c'est
vraiment un enjeu important pour les
communautés en 2016 à outremont un
référendum avait validé un règlement
pour interdire de nouveaux lieux de
culte sur les artères commerciales cinq
ans plus tard la question se pose à
nouveau la sorte ce rapport très bonne
chose le représentant du conseil juif
hassidique invoque notamment
l'impossibilité de se déplacer loin de
chez soi lors du shabbat et donc de se
rendre à une synagogue qui serait à plus
d'un kilomètre ces personnages là elle
n'a pas besoin en grande synagogue un
grand bâtiment et il y a juste besoin
d'un
petit comme je dis aux synagogues
dépanneur sénat goc où on peut juste
avoir 21 trentaine de personnes ça ne
pose pas problème des stations marre ça
ne pose pas problème un problème
d'aménagement il sait que l'enjeu du
stationnement irrite certains de ses
voisins en tout les assises et comptant
des mains un léger penchant pour faire
ce qu'ils veulent ah bon alors nous ça
nous fatigue un peu mais les avis sont
partagés ils y allaient mitigé après moi
ça se passe assez bien sa part est apte
à tenir les ironique il commence à
grandir et oui comme les chinois
les circonspects je cours tous les jours
et je vais jamais jamais croisé le
regard de taille restait peut-être leur
façon d'être et notre façon d'être et
c'est tout juste l'accepter mais
finalement la multiplication des
synagogues est ce que ça va changer
quelque chose parce qu'on va dire bon
vous avez assez de lieux de culte non ça
changera rien ils vont gagner c'est sûr
que moi j qu'en 25 ans ici ça va être à
nouveau ghetto juif il ya ce sentiment
kyrielle que peut-être potentiellement
un jour autre mon pourrait ressembler à
ce qu'on observe par exemple à brooklyn
ou à williams martyn williams burg on
vous avait un quartier qui est quasiment
à 100% 100% l'assedic
dans sa galerie d'art qu'il inaugure
dans quelques jours cet iranien
d'origine veut symboliser l'endroit où
se trouvait la torah ici lorsque c'était
une synagogue la communauté bl ont été
mes locataires mes voisins et mes amis
dans les dernières années ils ont grandi
rapidement et arrive à 110 je pense j'ai
besoin d'un plus grand espace un ancien
bar devenu synagogue puis lieux
culturels tout un symbole qu'on a gardé
le père ni de lieu cultuel permis de
lieux de culte
tout simplement parce que on veut garder
cet aspect disons spirituel on veut se
garder cet aspect qui unit les deux
mondes ici ni le nouveau maire
d'outremont ni celui du plateau mont
royal n'ont souhaité s'exprimer sur le
sujet un nouveau rapport doit être
déposé ce soir au conseil
d'arrondissement d'oultremont sur le
partage de l'espace public entre
hassidique et non hassidique de la
matière supplémentaire pour réfléchir au
vivre ensemble si mathieu prost radio
canada montréal
alors gagner le qu'est ce que j'en
pensais le jeu commence avec vous ce
qu'on doit ou non permettre
l'établissement de nouvelles sinagra
sais je ne pense pas non je pense que il
faut malheureusement le mile end
outremont ce sont des quartiers qui sont
déjà construits avec une population déjà
existantes et des commerçants des
commerces déjà présents on ne peut pas
aller fini à grandir le nombre de
synagogues lorsque j'étais maire jean
j'ai accepté je nous avons accepté les
permis de nombreuses synagogues nous
allons transformer une usine aux
synagogues nous avons d'ailleurs à
condition que les ateliers d'artistes
soit maintenu dans les étages on a
accepté la transformation de locaux de
maisons résidentielles en synagogue mais
à un moment donné il ya une limite parce
que comme le disait non comme on dit
dans le reportage c'est un lieu de vie
le stock c'est à lui de vie un lieu de
célébration un lieu de prière est un
lieu où les gens se rendre à plusieurs
occasions contrairement à la mosquée on
peut prier dans la région musulmane où
qu'on soit d'ailleurs c'est pour ça pour
un ménage des locaux de prière dans les
universités par exemple on n'est pas
obligé d'aller à la mosquée tandis que
la synagogue on est obligé d'y aller du
moins pour les hassidiques et donc et
comme c'est mentionné aussi les gens ne
veulent pas se déplacer sur de longues
distances alors nîmes des synagogues se
multiplient d'autant plus qu'il y a six
communautés une communauté distincte
elle n'utilise pas les mêmes synagogue
alors la croissance du nombre de
synagogues ne faiblit jamais et ça pose
un problème non pas d'intégration parce
que l'intégration au niveau social est
assez bonne ça propose un problème
d'urbanisme dont annie est ce que vous
diriez nom aussi ce soir qui vient
prendre la décision mais je vous dirais
que j'ai la même position que l'udc là
dessus moi j'étais dans un
arrondissement on avait 115 communautés
culturelles on en à 220 à montréal
chacun surtout chacun à leur propre
religion moi j'ai eu le même débat avec
la communauté haïtienne avec les
musulmans également aussi où on voyait
des mosquées ou envoyer des églises
évangéliques appareils dans des garages
et ça nuit au développement du quartier
c'est pas c'est pas de façon religieuse
mais on est des plans d'urbanisme qui
disent que des rues qui sont voués à ça
il ya des rues que son résidentiel avec
des usages le plan d'urbanisme définit
comment on doit vivre ensemble dans
chacun de nos quartiers et ce à partir
du moment où on investit des résidences
pour en faire une synagogue ou une
mosquée où un lieu de culte ça change la
dynamique sur les rues parce que c'est
une rue résidentielle la même chose avec
les commerces et on peut pas définir une
synagogue où je vous dis je l'inclus
avec les autres lieux de culte comme
dans des des commerces qui ne sont pas
voués à ça on les rues commerciales dans
lesquels on peut les mettre encore une
fois les derniers règlements d'urbanisme
il ya quelques années la vie et le mythe
des règlements pour ne pas en avoir une
à côté de l'autre juste l'impôt le
stationnement la qualité de vie que les
gens qui marchent si les rues donc c'est
vraiment un dossier qui est pas simple
donc jade d'accord avec luxure il faut
après une certaine limite qu'on dise non
et qu'ils jugent de sens il conseil
d'arrondissement à le classer
ce qui se passe c'est que le concept de
roadster peut décider que nous vivons à
avoir une affectation commercial mais va
permettre des synagogues mais souvent
les hassidiques ne veulent pas aller sur
ce terrain là parce que je considère que
le local est trop cher par exemple alors
préfère viser des locaux résidentiels
sur des bouts de rue des arts des
bouddhas retard par exemple avenue du
parc au nord de bernard où il reste
encore
c'est une artère mais c'est du
résidentiel et il préfère ses locaux là
il faut essayer de les attirer en dehors
des zones où on ne se concentre pas ce
que moment donné même poru lorsqu'on
parle de l'intégration
et lorsqu'on parle de la mixité du vivre
ensemble ça ne peut se produire que si
une mixité pas s'il ya une domination
complète d'un gros sur une rue ou un
ensemble de vue alors moi je comprends
les hassidiques de nos familles
grandissent nos communautés grandissent
la synagogue c'est au coeur de notre vie
ce ne sont pas des communautés riche
dans certains cas puisque il consacre
beaucoup de temps la prière alors il
requiert des bas des bâtiments mais il
faut savoir il faut y voir où l'on
négocié par exemple négocier des temps
de déplacement
pour aller par exemple sur 20 ha dorn où
il ya des espaces et sur
la rue bernard ok très bien bon ben
c'est tout c'est tout le temps qu'on a
c'est tout le temps qu'on a chez désolé
merci beaucoup à vous deux c était très
clair merci on se reparle très bientôt
au revoir bon début de semaine